We're going to be continuing with Chapter 10.
This is the fourth part, Part D for the muscular system.
If you have not viewed the previous three,
please be sure to look for those in the description below.
And in addition to that, they are also in the playlist.
If you have any questions, please email me.
You can find my information in the description area below.
Send me a message through the YouTube or on Facebook,
or just leave a comment below.
I would prefer that you email me directly.
Reason being is sometimes I don't end up
getting comments for whatever reason
I'm not able to reply back to you.
I've had a few instances where a few of you have asked
questions, and for one reason or another,
I was not able to reply back in the comments section.
So if you email me, I'll get it.
Most likely, I'll end up getting your email.
And then I'll get back to you quite much more quickly
than I'll probably through YouTube.
OK, so let's move forward.
So we're going to be looking at the muscles that
are crossing the shoulder joint.
And these are responsible for the movements of your arm.
Remember, that's the humer's bone.
So again, going back to the shoulder joint.
So you guys remember that the shoulder joint,
it's a ball and socket joint.
And this is the most flexible joint
that we have in our body.
But because it's the most flexible joint,
it's not very stable.
So it's a highly instable joint.
Several muscles across each shoulder joint
to insert onto the humer's.
All the muscles that are acting on the humer's
originate from the petrol girdle.
However, we have two of these muscles,
the latimis dorsi and the pectoralis
major, which originate on the axial skeleton.
So up to nine muscles that cross the shoulder joint.
Only the pectoralis major, the latissimus dorsi,
and the deltoid muscles are the primulis of arm movement.
The remaining muscles are synergies and fixators.
Now, four of these muscles, the supraspinatus, infraspinatus,
terrace minor, and the subscapularis,
they make up the rotator cuff muscles.
They originate on the scapula and their tendons
they blend in with the fibrous capsule
of the shoulder joint on their way to the humerus.
While the rotator cuff muscles act as synergists
in the angular and rotational movements of the arm,
their main function is to reinforce the capsule
of the shoulder joint to prevent dislocation of the humerus.
The other two muscles, the terrace major
and the chorarchal brachialis,
while they cross the shoulder joint,
they don't contribute to its reinforcement.
Generally speaking, muscles that originate
anterior to the shoulder joint,
so we're talking about the pectoralis major,
the chorarchal brachialis and the anterior fibers
of the deltoid, they flex the arm,
so like when you're lifting something anteriorly,
these are the muscles that play.
Now, the prime mover of arm flexion
is the pectoralis major.
The biceps brachia of the arm,
it also assists in this action.
Muscles are originating posterior to the shoulder joint,
they extend the arm, these include your latissimus dorsi,
the posterior fibers of the deltoid muscles
and the terrace major.
The latissimus dorsi and pectoralis muscles
are antagonist of one other
in the flexion and sanction movements of the arm.
The middle region of the deltoid muscle,
which extends over the super lateral side of the humerus,
is a prime mover of arm abduction.
The main arm abductors are the pectoralis major anteriorly
and the latissimus dorsi posteriorly.
So here we have an illustration
that's showing you the shoulder joint.
And this first muscle that we're gonna be looking at
is this pectoralis major.
So this is a large fan shaped muscle
that's covering the superior portion of the chest.
It forms the anterior axillary fold
and it's divided into equivicular and sternal parts.
The origin is gonna be the sternal end of the clavicle,
the sternum, the cartlages of ribs one through six
and sometimes seven, and the aponeurosis
of the external oblique muscles.
As for the insertion, the fibers they converge
to insert by a short tendon
into the intertubercular sulcus
and the greater tubercle of the humerus.
As for the actions, this is a prime mover
of arm flexion.
It rotates the arms medially
and it also adducts the arms against resistance.
Now with the scapula and the arms in a fixed position,
it pulls the ribcage upwards.
So this helps you in climbing and throwing
and pushing and enforced inspiration.
Now this thick multi-painite muscle
that's forms the rounded shoulder masses, the deltoid.
And this is a site that's commonly used
for administering intramuscular injections,
specifically in men because men typically have a larger,
more prominent deltoid than in females.
The other place that you give injections
is the gluteus maximus, your butt muscle.
Its insertion is a deltoid tuberosity of the humerus
and as for the origin, it embraces the insertion
of the trapezius, the lateral third of the clavicle,
in addition to the chromium and spine of the scapula.
It's innervated by the axillary nerve
and as for its actions,
when all the fibers contract simultaneously,
it acts as the prime mover of arm abduction.
It's an antagonist of the petros major
in the latissimus dorsi, which adduct the arm.
Now if only the anterior fibers are active,
it can actually act as a powerful muscle inflection
and medial rotation of the humerus.
So because of that, it's said to be a synergies
of the petros major as well.
Now if only a posterior fibers are active,
it causes extension and lateral rotation of the arm.
This muscle is also active when we're walking
and our arms are swinging.
Now we're gonna be looking at this broad, flat,
triangular muscle of our lower back,
which you find around our lumbar region.
This is the latissimus dorsi.
It's covered by the trapezius superiorly
and it contributes to the posterior wall of the axilla.
Its insertion is gonna be the intertuberculic groove
of the humerus and as for the origin,
there's gonna be several sites.
So we have the spinous process of T7 all the way down
to extending down to L5 of the vertebrae,
the iliic crest of the sacrum, the thoracol lumbar fascia,
the inferior angle of the scapula,
and the lower three or four ribs.
It's innervated by the thoracol door.
So nerves, so specifically we're looking at cervical nerves,
six cervical nerves, seven and cervical nerve, eight.
The subscapularis is a rotator cuff muscle.
It forms part of the posterior wall of the axilla
and its tendon of insertion passes in front
of the shoulder joint.
Its insertion is a lesser tubercle of the humerus
and as for the origin, it's a subscapular fossa
of the scapula.
It's innervated by the subscapular nerves.
So we're looking at cervical nerves, five cervical nerves,
six and cervical nerves, seven.
As far as for its actions go,
it's a chief medial rotator of the arm.
It's assisted by the pectoralis major
and it helps hold the head of the humerus
in the glenoid cavity stabilizing the shoulder joint.
The supraspinatus muscle, which is a rotator cuff muscle,
which runs deep to the trapezius,
is named for its location on the posterior aspect of the scapula.
Its origin is a supraspinus fossa of the scapula
and as for the insertion, it's a superior part
of the greater tubercle of the humerus.
It's innervated by the supraspapular nerve
and its prime action is to initiate abduction of the arms.
It also helps stabilize the shoulder joint
and it helps prevent downward dislocation of the humerus.
So when you're carrying something heavy,
like a gallon of milk or a suitcase,
this is one of the muscles that's helped preventing your arm
from being dislocated.
As you can see, the deltoid has been cut out
and because it's been cut out,
we can see this one next muscle here,
the infraspinatus.
So it's partially covered by the deltoid
and the trapezius as well.
It's named for its scapular location
and it's also another one of the rotator cuff muscles.
Its origin is gonna be the infraspinus fossa of the scapula
and the insertion is gonna be the greater tubercle
of the humerus posterior to the insertion
of the supraspinatus.
Like the supraspinatus,
it's also innervated by the supraspapular nerve.
As for its actions, primary action is to rotate
the arms laterally and it also helps hold the head
of the humerus in the glenoid cavity.
Again, to further stabilize the shoulder joint.
The next rotator cuff muscle we're gonna be looking at
is the terrace minor muscle.
And this is a small elongated muscle.
It lies inferior to the infraspinatus
and sometimes it may be inseparable.
Its origin is the lateral border
of the dorsal scapular surface
and for the insertion, it's a greater tubercle
of the humerus inferior to the infraspinatus insertion.
As far as its actions go,
they're gonna be the same as the infraspinatus muscles.
We're talking about rotating the arm laterally
and it's innervated by the axillary nerve.
Next, we move on to the terrace major.
And this is a thick rounded muscle
it's located inferior to the terrace minor
and it helps form the posterior wall of the axilla
along with latsysimus dorsi and the subscapularis.
Its origin is the posterior surface of the scapula
at the inferior angle and its insertion is the crust
of the lesser tubercle on the anterior humerus.
Its insertion tendon, it gets fused
with that of the latsysimus dorsi.
Its prime actions include extending,
medially rotating and adducting the arm.
It's also synergis of the latsysimus dorsi.
It's innervated by the lower subscapular nerve
so we're looking at cervical nerve six
and cervical nerve seven.
Finally, we come to the chorocal brachialis
and this is a small cylindrical muscle.
Its origin is the chorocoid process of the scapula
and it inserts into the medial surface of the humerus shaft.
Its actions to flex and adduct the arms
and it's the synergis of the petrelis major
and it's innervated by the muscular cutaneous nerve.
There's also several animations for these muscles
that we discussed.
So be sure you view them all.
There's one for the pectros major muscle over here,
another one here for the deltoid muscle,
another one over here for that shows you
the latsysimus dorsi.
Then we have one here for the subscapularis,
the supraspinatus and the infraspinatus.
Again, you can find these on the Pearson website
or with the DVD that may have come with your book.
In addition to that, you can always look for it on YouTube.
There's another one for the terrace minor,
one for the terrace major.
There's several more videos for the muscles
that act on the shoulder joint and humerus.
So this is an overview, another overview video.
And again, this one shows the muscles
that cross the glenohumeral joint.
One shows movements that form at the rotator cuff
and there's another one that shows movements
at the rotator cuff.
Again, there's another one for the glenohumeral joint.
There's another one.
And again, yet another one.
And here's one more.
And I think this is the last one
for the glenohumeral joint.
So please be sure you view all of these.
Again, you can find them at the Pearson website
or the DVD that came with your book
in addition to that, you can search for it on YouTube.
Now we're gonna be looking at muscles
that are crossing the elbow joint
for a flexion and extension of the forearm.
So muscles that are standing out across the upper arm
and going to the elbow joint,
they insert on the forearm bones.
Now since the elbow is a hinge joint,
movements promoted by these arm muscles,
they're limited almost entirely to flexion
and extension of the forearm.
Walls of the fascia,
they divide the arm into two muscle compartments.
We have the posterior extensors and the anterior flexors.
The main forearm extensor is a triceps brachii muscle,
which forms nearly the entire musculature
or the posterior compartment.
All the anterior arm muscles,
they flex the forearm at the elbow joint.
And these are the brachialis, the biceps brachii
and the brachior radialis muscles.
Now the brachialis and the biceps,
they insert into the ulna and the radius respectively.
And they contract simultaneously during flexion.
And these are the chief forearm flexors.
Just about everybody is familiar with the biceps brachii muscle
because when we flex our forearm,
this is the muscle that bulges out.
Now the one that's not as well known is the brachialis.
Now this lies deep to the biceps,
but it says equally as important during the flexion.
So it's a synergist of the biceps brachii.
The brachior radialis also helps flex the arm,
but it's a weak forearm flexor.
Now the only muscle that we find on the posterior compartment
of the arm is this large, fleshy triceps brachii muscle.
It has three-headed origin.
The long and the lateral heads,
they lie superficial to the medial head.
So for the origin of the long head,
it's the infraglinoid tubercle of the scapula.
The lateral head, we find the insertion
on the posterior shaft of the humerus.
And for the medial head, it's the posterior humeral shaft
distal to the radial groove.
As for the insertion, it's by the common tendon
that goes into the lurkman process of the ulna.
It's prime action is a powerful forearm extensor
and it's an antagonist of the forearm flexors.
The long and lateral heads, they're mainly active
in extension against resistance
and it's innervated by the radial nerve.
The anconias, which is a short triangle in muscles,
partially blended with the distal end
of the triceps on the posterior aspect of the humerus.
Its origin is a lateral epicondyle of the humerus
and its insertion is a lateral aspect
of the ulnar crown process of the ulna.
Its primary action is to control ulnar abduction
during forearm pronation.
And it's also a synergist of the triceps brachii
during elbow extensions.
And as far as this nurse supply goes,
it's innervated by the radial nerve.
So these are the two posterior muscles of the elbow joint.
So be sure to watch this video over here
for the triceps brachii muscle.
Again, go to the Pearson website
or the DVD that came with your book
in addition to searching on YouTube.
And now we're gonna be looking at the anterior muscles
of the elbow joint.
So we start off with this biceps brachii muscle.
It's a two-headed fusiform muscle.
The bellies they unite as the insertion point is approached.
At the tendon of the long head,
it also helps to stabilize the shoulder joint.
The origin for the short head is the core quad process.
And for the long head is a super glenoid tubercle
and the lip of the glenoid cavity.
The tendon of the long head,
it runs within the capsule
and into the intertrovicular sulcus of the humerus.
The insertion is by a common tendon
into the radial tuberosity.
Its prime action is to flex the elbow joint
and supinate the forearms.
These actions, they usually occur at the same time.
So when you're taking a bottle of olive oil
and you're pulling the cork out.
So as you pull the cork out,
think about when you're turning the cork
and then pulling back up and flexing the arm.
This is the action that's happening
and provided by this biceps brachii muscle.
And it's innervated by the muscular cutaneous nerve.
The brachii out of muscle is a strong muscle
that's immediately deep to the biceps brachii
on the distal humerus.
Its origin is the front of the distal humerus
and it embraces the insertion of the deltoid muscle.
For the insertion is the coronite process of the ulna
and the capsule of the elbow joint.
Like the biceps brachii,
it's also innervated by the muscular cutaneous nerve.
And for its action, it's a major forearm flexor.
It lifts the ulna as a biceps lifts the radius.
Now we'll look at the brachioradialis muscle.
This is a superficial muscle of the lateral forearm.
It forms a lateral boundary of the cuboidal fossa
and it extends from the distal humerus
to the distal forearm.
Its origin is the lateral supercondola ridge
at the distal end of the humerus
and the insertion is the base of the styloid process
of the radius.
It's a synergist and forearm flexion
and it works best when the forearm is partially flexed
and semi-pronated.
It also stabilizes the elbow
during rapid flexion and extension.
It's innervated by the radial nerve
and this is an exception
as the radial nerve typically serves extensor muscles.
So be sure to watch this animation
on the biceps brachii.
Here's another one for the brachialis
and another for the brachioradialis.
And there's an overview of the elbow joint in the forearm
and this one's for the muscles of the elbow joint
and looks like one more for muscles of the elbow joint.
And we have another for the elbow joint.
So please be sure to view view of these animations.
You can expect questions on the exam
from these animations is highly likely.
So please be sure to look out for these.
Again, go to the website for Pearson.
You can look for it on YouTube in addition to that.
If your book came with the DVD, look for it on that.
Now we're gonna be moving on to the muscles of the forearm
and these are responsible for movements of your wrist,
your hands and fingers.
The muscles of the forearm perform several basic functions.
Some cause wrist movements, others move the fingers
and thumbs and a few help pronate and supinate the forearm.
In most cases, they're fleshy portions,
they contribute to the roundness of the proximal forearm
and then they taper to long tendons distally
to insert into the hand.
At the wrist, these tendons, they're securely anchored
by a band-like dignity of deep fascia
that's called flexor and extensor retiniculae.
These bands at the wrist,
they keep the tendons from jumping outwards when tensed.
Crowd it together in the wrist and palm,
the muscle tendons are surrounded by slippery tendon she said,
minimize friction as they slide against one another.
The forearm muscles are subdivided by fascia
into two main compartments,
the anterior flexors and the posterior extensors,
each with superficial and deep muscle layers.
So the anterior muscles, they're flexors,
they insert via the flexor retiniculum
and the posterior muscles, which are the extensors,
they insert play the extensor retiniculum.
Most flexors in the anterior compartment
arise from a common tendon on the humerus
and are innervated largely by the median nerve.
The two anterior compartment muscles are not flexors
but pronators, the pronator terrace
and the pronator quadratus.
And pronation is one of the most important forearm movements.
Muscles of the posterior compartment
they extend the wrist and fingers.
One exception is a supinator muscle,
which assists the biceps brachii muscle of the arm
in supinating the forearm.
Of the eight muscles of the anterior compartment,
five of them are superficial and three of them are deep.
Most of them they arise from a common flexor tendon
and they're attached to the medial epicondyle of the humerus
and they have additional origins as well.
Most of the tendons and insertion of these flexors
they're held in place at the wrist
by a thickening of deep fascia called the flexor retiniculum.
First we're gonna be looking at the pronator terrace muscle.
This is the two-hydrous muscles
and when we're looking at it in a superficial view
you can find it between the proximal margins
of the brachii radialis and the flexor carpi radialis.
It forms a medial boundary of the cuboidal fossa.
It's origins and medial epicondyle of the humerus
and the coronite process of the ulna.
It's insertions by a common tendon,
mid shafts on the lateral aspect of the radius.
It's prime action is to pronate the forearm
and it's also a weak flexor of the elbow.
It's innervated by the median nerve.
Next we look at the flexor carpi radialis muscle
and this runs diagonally across the forearm.
Midway it's fleshy belly, it's replaced by a flat tendon
that becomes cord-like at the wrist.
So you can see that over here.
It's origin is the medial epicondyle of the humerus
and it's insertion is the base
of the second and third metacarpals.
The insertion tendons easily seen
and it provides as a guide to the position
of the radial artery and this is useful
when taking a pulse and also in obtaining blood gases
when you're taking what's called an arterial blood gas.
This is one of the landmarks that you use.
You wanna go lateral to that tendon when you feel it.
It's prime action is as a powerful flexor of the wrist
and it abducts the hand and it's also weak synergies
of elbow flexion.
It's also innervated by the median nerve.
The palm is longest which is a small fleshy muscle
with a long insertion tendon.
It may be used as a guide to find the median nerve
that lies lateral to it at the wrist.
It's origin is the medial epicondyle of the humerus
and the insertion is the palm or aponeurosis.
It's also innervated by the median nerve.
Its prime action is to tense the skin and fascia
of the palm during hand movements.
It's also weak wrist flexor in addition
to being a weak synergist for elbow flexion
and it's also innervated by the median nerve.
Next we're gonna be looking at this flexor
carbide ulnerus muscle.
It's a two-headed muscle
and it's the most medial muscle of the group.
The ulnar nerve also lies lateral to its tendon.
The origin is the medial epicondyle of the humerus
and the olecranon process
and posterior surface of the ulnar.
The insertion is gonna be the pisiform and the hemate bones
and base of the fifth metacarpal.
The prime action for this muscle
is that it's a powerful flexor of the wrist
and it also adducts the hand
in concert with the extensor carbide ulnerus.
In addition to that,
it also stabilizes the wrist during finger extensions
and it's innervated by the ulnar nerve.
And finally, we have the flexor
digitorum superficialis muscle.
It's a two-headed muscle that's more deeply placed
and it's overlain by muscles above
but it's still visible at the distal end of the forearm.
As far as origin,
it's the medial epicondyle of the humerus,
the cornered process of the ulnar
and the shaft of the radius.
It's insertion is by four tendons
into the middle flanges of fingers two, three, four, and five.
It's innervated by the median nerve
and its prime action is that it flexes the wrist
and middle flanges of fingers two, three, four, and five.
And this is an important finger flexor
when speed and flushing against resistance are required.
Now we're gonna be looking at the deep muscles of the forearm
and the first one we're gonna be looking at
is the flexor polysis longus
and it's partially covered by the flexor
digitorum superficialis
and it parallels the flexor digitorum profundis laterally.
It's origin is the anterior surface of the radius
and the introsseous membrane
and the insertion is the distal failings of the thumb
and its prime action is to flex the distal failings of the thumb
and it's innervated by a branch of the median nerve.
So we're looking at cervical nerve eight
and the first thoracic nerve.
Now we're gonna be looking at the flexor digitorum profundis
and this muscle has extensive origins.
It's overlain entirely by the flexor
digitorum superficialis.
The origins it has include the cornered process,
the anterior medial surface of the ulnar
and the introsseous membrane.
Its insertion is by four tendons
into the distal flanges of fingers two, three, four and five.
Its prime action is that it flexes the distal
interflangeal joints.
It's also a slow acting flexor of any or all the fingers
and it is this inflexing the wrist.
As to its nerve supply,
the medial half is innervated by the ulnar nerve
and the lateral half is innervated by the median nerve.
And lastly, we're at the pronator quadratus.
This is the deepest muscle of the distal forearm.
It passes downward and laterally
and this is the only muscle that arises solely
from the ulnar and inserts solely into the radius.
Its origin is a distal portion of the anterior ulnar shaft
and its insertion is a distal surface
of the anterior radius.
It's innervated by the median nerve
and its action is that it's the prime move
of forearm pronation.
It also acts with the pronator teres
and it helps to hold the ulnar and radius together.
So be sure you view this muscle,
this video on the pronator teres
and this one on the fluxor carbide radialis.
We have another video here for the fluxor carbide ulnaris
and another one for the fluxor
digitorum superficialis.
And this is for the anterior muscles of the wrist
and fingers and this is a continuation of that.
So please be sure you watch these videos.
Look for them on YouTube or you can best think to do
is go to the Pearson website
and you'll have access to all this.
Or if your book came at the DVD, be sure to look at that.
Now we're going to be looking
at the posterior compartment muscles.
The consists of four superficial and four deep muscles.
They're all innervated by the radial nerve
or its branches and more than half of the posterior compartment
muscles, they arise from a common extensor origin tendon
that's attached to the posterior surface
of the lateral epicondyl of the humerus
and the adjacent fascia.
The extensor tendons are held in place
at the posterior aspect of the wrist
by the extensor retinaculum,
which prevents the bolstering of the attendants
when the wrist is hyper-extended.
The extensor muscles of the fingers
end in a broad hood over the dorsal side of the digits
called the extensor expansion.
So there's about five animations that go over
the muscles that we're going to be looking at.
So be sure you look at that.
So this is the first one.
It shows you the posterior muscles of the wrist and fingers.
This other one, this is a continuation of part B.
This one goes over the extensor carb by Radialis Longus.
This goes over the extensor carb by Radialis Brevis.
And this one goes over the extensor Digitorum.
And we have the extensor carb by Oneris over here.
So be sure that you view all these animations
either on the Pearson website, the DVD
that may have come with your book,
or you can always look for it on YouTube.
So the first superficial muscle that we're
going to be looking at is the extensor carb by Radialis Longus.
And this parallels with the brachior Radialis
on the lateral forearm, and it may blend with it.
Its origin is a lateral supercondular ridge of the humerus,
and its insertion is the base of the second metacarpal.
Now its prime actions are to extend and abduct the wrist.
It extends the wrist in conjunction
with the extensor carb by Oneris, and it
abducts the wrist in conjunction with the flexor carb by Radialis.
And it's innervated by the Radial nerve.
The extensor carb by Radialis Brevis muscle
lies deep to the extensor carb by Radialis Longus,
and is somewhat shorter than it.
Its origin is a lateral epicano of the humerus,
and its insertion is the base of the third metacarpal.
It's innervated by the deep branch of the Radial nerve,
and its prime action is to extend and abduct the wrist.
It also acts as a synergist with the extensor carb by Radialis
Longus to steady the wrist during finger flexion.
The extensor digitorum lies medial to the extensor carb by Radialis
Brevis.
A detached portion of it, called the extensor digiti
minimae, it extends to the little finger, as you can see,
going right down here.
Its origin is a lateral epicondale of the humerus,
and its insertion is by four tendons
into the extensor expansion and the distal phalanges
of fingers two, three, four, and five.
Its action is that it's a prime mover of the finger extension,
and it also extends the wrist and can abduct the fingers,
so it's when you're flaring your fingers.
And it's innervated by the posterior intra osteos nerve.
This long slender muscle is extensor carb by onaris.
It's the most medial of the superficial posterior muscles.
Its origin is a lateral epicondale of the humerus,
and the posterior border of the ona.
Its insertion is the base of the fifth metacarpal.
Its action is to extend the wrist in conjunction
with the extensor carb by Radialis,
and it adducts the wrist in conjunction
with the flexor carb by onaris.
And it's innervated by the posterior intra osteos nerve.
And there's more animations for you guys to look at,
so please be sure to look at this.
This one's the posterior muscles of the wrist and fingers.
This is part A. This one's part B.
This shows the extensor carb by Radialis longas.
This one goes over the extensor carb by Radialis brevis.
And this one goes over the extensor digitorum.
And this goes over the extensor carb by onaris.
So be sure you've viewed these videos
either at the Pearson website on YouTube or in the CD
or the DVD that may have come with your book.
Now we're gonna be looking at the deep muscles.
So the first one we're gonna look at is the supinator.
And this is a deep muscle at the posterior aspect
of the elbow, and it's largely concealed
by the superficial muscles.
Its origin is the lateral epicondyle of the humerus
and the proximal ulna.
Its insertion is gonna be the proximal end of the radius.
And its main action assist is the biceps brachia
to forcibly supinate the forearm.
It works alone in slow supination also,
and it's an antagonist of the pronator muscles.
It's innervated by the posterior interosseous nerve.
Next, we have the abductor policies longest,
and this is lateral and parallel
to the extensor policies longest,
and it's just distal to the supinator.
Its origin is a posterior surface of the radius and ulna
and the interosseous membrane.
Its insertion is the base of the first metacarpal
and the trapezium.
And its action is to abduct and extend the thumb,
and it's innervated by the posterior interosseous nerve.
The extensor policies brevis and the extensor policies longest
is overlain by the extensor carpi ulneris.
Its origin is the dorsal shaft of the radius and ulna
and the interosseous membrane.
Its insertion is the base of the proximal
and distal feelings of the thumb.
Its prime action is to extend the thumb
and it's innervated by the posterior interosseous nerve.
Finally, we have the extensor indices right over here.
And this is a tiny muscle that's rising close to the wrist.
Its origin is the posterior surface of the distal ulna
and the interosseous membrane.
Its insertion is the extensor expansion of the index finger
and it joins the tendon of the extensor digitorum.
Its prime action is to extend the index finger
and it assists in wrist extension.
And it's innervated by the posterior interosseous nerve.
So be sure to view the animation.
This one shows the posterior lateral view of the supinator.
This one goes over the muscles of the forearm,
another one that goes over the muscles of the forearm,
and finally you have one more that goes over the muscles of the forearm.
So be sure to review all these animations.
Either go to the website for Pearson
or the disc that may have come with your book.
In addition to that, you should be able to find it on YouTube.
So in this illustration, what they're showing you
is that for the posterior compartment of the arm,
the muscles that extend the elbows
is innervated by the radial nerve
and the muscles that do the extending
are the triceps brachii.
And then for the muscles that are flexing,
your flexors in the anterior compartment of your arm,
it's innervated by the musculotrutaneous nerve
and you have your short head and the long head
of the biceps brachii and the brachialus muscle.
And here's your humerus over here.
And over here, you can see the blood vessels.
You have a vein, an artery, another vein, an artery.
And in this illustration here, they're
showing you the forearm, so the posterior compartment
of the forearm and it's responsible for extending
the wrist and fingers.
And it's innervated by the radial nerve.
So you can see the extensors over here.
And then over here, this is showing you
the anterior compartment of the forearm.
And these are the flexors that you're going to find here.
So this flexes the wrist and the fingers.
And it's innervated by the median or the ulnar nerve.
So when you look at these muscles over here,
we have the brachioradialus, the pronator
terrace, and the abductor, polysis longest.
And we have more animations here.
So this one's going over the muscles
that act on the wrist and fingers.
And another one that goes over the carpal tunnel.
And finally, there's another one that
goes over the rotating hand.
So again, please head over to the Pearson website
or you can search for it on YouTube
or go refer to the disc that may have come with your book.
Now we're going to be looking at the intrinsic muscles
with the hand, which are responsible for the fine moments
of the fingers.
All these small muscles are entirely in the palm
and none on the hands, dorsal side.
These small weak muscles mostly control precise movements,
leaving the powerful movements of the fingers
to the forearm muscles.
The intrinsic muscles include the main abductors
and adductors of the fingers, as well as muscles
that produce the movement of opposition, which
is moving the thumb towards the little finger.
In addition to that, it allows for movements
that enables your grip objects in the palm,
so as in when you're holding a baseball bat.
Some movements are defined differently
from the movements of the other fingers,
because the thumb lies at a right angle to the rest of the hand.
The thumb flexes by bending medally along the palm,
not by bending anteriorly as the other fingers do.
And the thumb extends by pointing laterally,
not posteriorly, as the other fingers do.
The interesting muscles of the palm
are divided into three groups.
Those in the thinare eminence, which is the ball of the thumb,
those that are in the hyper-thinare eminence,
which is the ball of the little fingers,
and those that are in the mid palm.
The thinner and the hyper-thinare muscles
are almost mirror images of one another.
Each contain a small flexor, an abductor,
and an opponent's muscle.
The mid-palmer muscles, called the lumberkels
and the introsia, they extend our fingers
at the interphalangeal joints.
The introsia are also the main finger
abductors and adductors.
We're going to start off by looking at the thinare muscles
in the ball of the thumb.
And the first muscle that we're going to be looking at
is the adductor pauses, brothers, which is right over here.
And this is a lateral muscle of the thinare group.
It's superficial.
So when you're abducting your thumb,
so when you bring your thumb towards your index finger,
that muscle that you see that's bulging out the muscles.
This is that muscle.
This is the adductor pauses, brothers.
Its origin is a flexor retinaculum
and the nearby carples.
And its insertion is the lateral base
of the thumb's proximal phalanx.
Its main action is to abduct the thumbs
at the carpal metacarpal joint.
And it's innervated by the median nerve.
Next, we have the flexor pauses brevis.
And this is the medial and deep muscle of the thinare group.
Its origin is a flexor retinaculum and nearby carples.
And the insertion is the lateral side
of the base of the proximal phalanx of the thumb.
Its prime action is that it flexes the thumb
at the carpal metacarpal and the metacarpal phalanxial joints.
And it's innervated by the median
and in occasionally the ulnar nerve.
Next, we have the adductor pauses.
This is a fan-shaped muscle with horizontal fibers.
Its distal to the other thinare muscles.
And it has oblique and transverse heads.
Its origin is a capitate bone and the bones of metacarpals
2, 3, and 4, in addition to the front of metacarpal 3.
And its insertion is the medial side
of the base of the proximal phalanx of the thumb.
As for its action, it adducts and helps to pose the thumb.
And it's innervated by the ulnar nerve.
The opponent's policies is deeply the adductor pauses
brevis on metacarpal 1.
Its origin is a flexor retinaculum and the trapezium.
And its insertion is the whole anterior side
of metacarpal 1.
Its prime movement is opposition.
So this is the muscle that allows you to move your thumb
and touch the tip of your little finger.
It's innervated by the median or occasionally
the ulnar nerve.
Now we're going to be looking at the hypoethenar muscles
in the ball of the little finger.
And the first one that we're going to be looking at
is the abductor digitai minimae.
And this is the medial muscle of the hypoethenar group.
And it's superficial.
Its origin is a pissiform bone.
And its insertion is the medial side
of the proximal phalanx of the little finger.
And its main action is to abduct the little fingers
at the metacarpal phalanxial joint.
And it's innervated by the ulnar nerve.
The flexor digitai minimum brevis.
It's a lateral deep muscle of the hypoethenar group.
Its origin is the hyamate bone and the flexor retinaculum.
Its insertion is same as the abductor digitai minimae.
And its action is to flex the little fingers
at the metacarpal phalanxial joint.
And it's also innervated by the ulnar nerve.
The opponent's digitai minimae is
deep through the abductor digitai minimae.
Its origin is the same as the flexor digitai minimae brevis.
And its insertion is most of the length of the medial side
of the metacarpal five.
Its action is that it helps in opposition.
It brings metacarpal five towards the thumb to cup the hand.
And it's also innervated by the ulnar nerve.
Now we're going to be moving on to the mid-palmer muscles.
And the first muscle we're going to be looking at
is the lumbercalls.
We have four of these warm-shaped muscles in our palm,
one to each finger with the exception of the thumb,
usually because they originate from the tendons
of another muscle.
So here you can see the first lumbercalls.
This is the second lumbercalls.
And this is the third lumbercall.
And this is the fourth lumbercall.
And as you can see, the origin is a lateral side
of each tendon of the flexor digitorum
profoundest in the palm.
Its insertion is a lateral edge of the extensor expansion
on the proximal failings of fingers two, three, four, and five.
And its action is to flex the fingers
at the metacarpal phalangeal joints.
But it also extends the fingers at the intra-phalangeal joints.
It's innervated by the lateral two million nerves
and the median two ulnar nerves.
The palma or interossii are four long, quench-shaped muscles
in the spaces between the metacarpals.
They lie ventral to the dorsal interossii.
Its origins on the side of each metacarpal
that faces the metac axis of the hand.
But it's absent from metacarpal three.
Its insertion is the extensor expansion
on the first failings of each finger, except for finger three,
and on the side facing the metac axis of the hand.
As for the action, these are the adductors of the fingers.
It pulls the fingers in towards the third digit.
It also acts with the lumbercalls
to extend the fingers at the intra-phalangeal joints
and flexes them at the metacarpal phalangeal joints.
For its nerves of flight, it's innervated by the ulnar nerve.
The dorsal interossii are four bipenic muscles
that are filling the spaces between the metacarpals.
These are the deepest palm muscles.
They're also visible on the dorsal side of the hand.
Its origin is the size of the metacarpals,
and the insertion are the extensor expansion
over the proximal failings of fingers two, three, and four
on the sides opposite the metac axis of the hand.
But on both sides of finger three.
And you can see that over here.
So here's the proximal failings.
And it's on the opposite side of the mid-axis.
This is the mid-axis.
So this is the opposite side of the mid-axis.
With the exception of-- so you can see it over here.
This is the opposite of the mid-axis,
the opposite of the mid-axis.
With the exception of the third digit,
we use your middle finger.
It's on both sides.
And its prime action is to abduct the fingers
or diverge the fingers.
In addition to that, it also extends the fingers
at the intra-phalangeal joints.
And it flexes them at the metacarpal phalangeal joints.
For a nervous apply, it's innervated by the ulnar nerve.
And that's it for this lecture.
So be sure to see the previous lectures
if you haven't seen those already.
In addition to that, if you have any questions,
please feel free to email me or send me a message
through YouTube or you can send me a message on Facebook.
My contact information is in the description below.
If you like the videos, please give it a big thumbs up.
And please also be sure to subscribe
if you haven't subscribed already.
And also, please share with your friends, your classmates,
and anybody else that you think may find it useful.
Thank you so much for watching.
And until next time.